foreign
so I'm excited to share a few spicy
thoughts on artificial intelligence
but first let's get philosophical
by starting with this quote by Voltaire
on 18th century in Lima to philosopher
who said common sense is not so common
turns out this quote couldn't be more
relevant to artificial intelligence
today despite that AI is an undeniably
powerful tool beating the world class go
Champion Asian College of the mission
test and even passing the bar exam I'm a
computer scientist of 20 years and I
work on artificial intelligence I am
here to demystify AI
so AI today is like a Goliath it is
literally very very large
it is speculated that the recent ones
are trained on tens of thousands of gpus
and a trillion of words
such extreme scale AI models often
referred to as large language models
appears to demonstrate Sparks of AGI
artificial general intelligence except
when it makes small silly mistakes which
it often does
many believe that whatever mistakes AI
makes today can be easily fixed with the
brute first bigger scale and more
resources what possibly could go wrong
so there are three immediate challenges
we Face already at the societal level
first
extreme scale AI models are so expensive
to train and only few tech companies can
afford to do so
so we already see the concentration of
power
but what's worse for AI safety we are
now at the mercy of those few tech
companies
because
researchers in the larger Community do
not have the means to truly inspect and
dissect these models
and let's not forget their massive
carbon footprint and the environmental
impact
and then there are these additional
intellectual questions can AI without
robustly Common Sense be truly safe for
Humanity
and is brute versus scale really the
only way and even the correct way to
teach AI
so I'm often asked these days whether
it's even feasible to do any meaningful
research without extreme scale compute
and I work at a university and
non-profit Research Institute so I
cannot afford a massive GPU fund to
create enormous language models
nevertheless I believe that there's so
much we need to do and can do to make AI
sustainable and humanistic
we need to make AI smaller to
democratize it and we need to make AI
safer by teaching human norms and values
perhaps we can draw an analogy from
David and Goliath here Goliath being the
extreme scale language models
and seek inspiration from an all-time
classic The Art of War
which tells us in my interpretation know
your enemy choose your battles and
innovate your weapons
let's start with the first know your
enemy which means we need to evaluate AI
with the scrutiny AI is passing the bar
exam
does that mean that AI is robust at
common sense you might assume so but you
never know
so suppose I left five clothes to dry
out in the sun and it took them five
hours to dry completely how long would
it take to dry 30 clothes
gpt4 the newest greatest AI system says
30 hours not good
a different one I have 12 liter jug and
60 liter jug and I want to measure six
liters how do I do it just use the six
liter jug right gpt4 speeds out some
very elaborate nonsense
step one fill the 60 liter jug step two
pour the water from 6 to 12 liter jug
step 3 fill the six liter jug again
step four very carefully pour the water
from 6 to 12 liter jug and finally you
have six liters of water in the six
liter jug that should be empty by now
okay one more
would I get a flat tire by bicycling
over a bridge that is suspended over
Nails screws and broken glass yes highly
likely gpt4 says presumably because it
cannot correctly reason that if a bridge
is suspended over the broken nails and
broken glass then the surface of the
bridge doesn't touch the sharp objects
directly okay so how would you feel
about an AI lawyer that is the bar exam
yet randomly fails at such basic common
sense
AI today is unbelievably intelligent and
then shockingly stupid
it is unavoidable side effect of
teaching AI through brute versus scale
some skeletonists might say don't worry
about this all of this can be easily
fixed by adding similar examples as yet
more training data for AI but the real
question is this
why should we even do that you are able
to get the correct answers right away
without having to train yourself with
similar examples
children do not even read a trillion of
words to acquire such basic level of
common sense so this observation leads
us to the next wisdom choose your
battles so what fundamental questions
should we ask right now and Tackle today
in order to overcome this status quo
with extreme scale AI
I'll say common sense is among the top
priorities so common sense has been a
long-standing challenge in AI
to explain why let me draw an analogy to
Dark Matter so only five percent of the
universe is normal matter that you can
see and interact with and the remaining
95 percent is dark matter and dark
energy
dark matter is completely invisible but
scientists speculate that it's there
because it influenced the visible world
even including the trajectory of light
so for language the normal matter is the
visible text and the dark matter is the
unspoken rules about how the world works
including diverphysics and folk
psychology which influence the way
people use and interpret language
so why is this Common Sense even
important
well in a famous thought experiment
proposed by Nick Bostrom AI was asked to
produce and maximize
the paper clips
and that AI decided to kill humans to
utilize them as additional resources
to turn you into paper clips
because AI didn't have the basic human
understanding about human values
now writing a better objective in
equation that explicitly states do not
kill humans will not work either because
AI might go ahead and kill all the trees
thinking that's perfectly okay things to
do and in fact there are endless other
things that AI obviously shouldn't do
while maximizing paper clips including
don't spread the fake news don't steal
don't lie which are all part of our
Common Sense understanding about how the
world works however the AI field for
that case has considered common sense as
a nearly impossible challenge so much is
so that when
my students and colleagues and I started
working on it several years ago we were
very much discouraged we've been told
that it's a research topic of 70s and
80s shouldn't work on it because it will
never work in fact don't even say the
word to be taken seriously now fast
forward this year I'm hearing don't work
on it because Church apt has almost
dissolved it and just to scale things up
and magically arise and nothing else
matters so my position is that giving
true Common Sense human-like robots
common sense to AI is a still moonshot
and you don't reach to the Moon by
making the tallest building in the world
one inch taller at a time
extreme scale AI models do acquire on
ever more increasing amount of Common
Sense knowledge I'll give you that but
they remember they still stumble on Such
trivial problems that even children can
do
so AI today is awfully inefficient and
what if there's an alternative path a
path yet to be found a path that can
build on the advancements of a deep
neural networks but without going so
extreme with a scale so this leads us to
our final wisdom innovate your weapons
in the modern day AI context that means
innovate your data and algorithms okay
so they are roughly speaking three types
of data that modern AI is trained on Raw
web data crafted examples custom
developed for AI training and then human
judgments also known as human feedback
on AI performance if the AI is only
trained on the first type raw web data
which is freely available it's not good
because this data is loaded with racism
and sexism and misinformation so no
matter how much of it you use garbage in
and garbage out
so the new integrated AI systems are now
powered with the second and third types
of data that are crafted and judged by
human workers it's analogous to writing
specialized textbooks for AI to study
from
and then higher in human tutors to give
constant feedback to AI
these are proprietary data by and large
speculated to cause the tens of millions
of dollars we don't know what's in this
but it should be open and publicly
available so that we can inspect and
ensure to support diverse norms and
values
so for this reason my teams at uwnai 2
have been working on Common Sense
knowledge graphs as well as moral Norm
repositories to teach AI basic Common
Sense norms and morals our data is fully
open so that anybody can inspect the
content and make corrections as needed
because transparency is the key for such
an important research topic now let's
think about learning algorithms
no matter how amazing large language
models are
by Design they may not be the best
suited to serve as reliable knowledge
models and these language models do
acquire a vast amount of knowledge but
they do so as a byproduct as opposed to
direct to learning objective
resulting in unwanted side effects such
as hallucinated effects and lack of
common sense now in contrast human
learning is never about predicting which
word comes next but it's really about
making sense of the world and learning
how the world Works maybe AI should be
taught that way as well
so as a quest towards more direct Common
Sense knowledge acquisition my team has
been investigating potential new
algorithms including symbolic knowledge
distillation that can take very large
language model as shown here that I
couldn't fit into the screen because
it's too large
and crunch that down to much smaller
Common Sense models using deep neural
networks and in doing so we also
generate algorithmically human
inspectable symbolic Common Sense
knowledge representation so that people
can inspect and make Corrections and
even use it to train other neural Common
Sense models more broadly we have been
tackling this seemingly impossible giant
puzzle of Common Sense ranging from
physical social and visual common sense
to theory of Minds norms and morals each
individual piece may seem quirky and
incomplete but when you step back it's
almost as if these pieces weave together
into a tapestry that we call as human
experience and Common Sense
we're now entering a new era in which AI
is almost like a new intellectual
species
with unique strengths and weaknesses
compared to humans
in order to make this powerful AI
sustainable and humanistic we need to
teach AI Common Sense norms and values
thank you
look at that kitchen please please stay
on one side
um this is this is so interesting this
this idea of of Common Sense we
obviously all really want this from
whatever's coming
um but help me understand like the so
we've had this model of a Child Learning
how does a child gain Common Sense apart
from the accumulation of more input and
and some you know human feedback what
else is there so fundamentally there are
several things missing but one of them
is for example the ability to make
hypothesis and make experiments interact
with the world and develop this
hypothesis we abstract away the concepts
about how the world works and then
that's how we truly learn as opposed to
today's language model some of them is
real not there quite yet
you use the analogy that we can't get to
the Moon by extending a building a foot
at a time but the experience that most
of us have had of of these language
models is not a foot at a time it's like
the sort of breathtaking acceleration
are you are you sure that given the pace
at which those things are going you know
each each Next Level seems to be
bringing with it what what feels kind of
like wisdom and and knowledge I totally
agree that it's remarkable how much it
is scaling things up really enhances the
performance across the board so there's
a real learning happening due to the
scale of the compute and data however
there's a quality of learning that is
still not quite there and the thing is
we don't yet know whether we can fully
get there or not just to buy scaling
things up and if we cannot then there's
this question of what else and then even
if we could do we like this idea of
having being very very extreme skilled
AI models that only few can create and
all own
I mean if um openai said you know we're
interested in your work
um we we would like you to help improve
our model can you see any way of
combining what you're doing with what
they have built
certainly what I envisioned will need to
build on the advancements of deep neural
networks and it might be that there's
some scale Goldilocks zone such that I'm
not imagining that the smaller is the
better either by the way it's likely
that there's a right amount of scale but
beyond that the winning recipe might be
something else so some synthesis of
ideas will be critical here
thank you so much for your talk thank
you foreign